well if this doesn't just make your day
super zoo going on at mandalay bay all
week long we are talking dogs and pets
and i've got larry k and spider here
this morning we're talking about how to
train your dog effectively larry we
won't tell the world that mine is
well i'm going to call him untrainable
but he will sit let's see some of the
fun things that spider can do well
spider loves his big ball he
will drive it all around this studio if
you let him oh my gosh
another basic trick you can teach your
dog at home is getting on a platform
this raised platform okay it helps dogs
to focus it's like a special place and
it boosts their
confidence to get up in front of a live
audience okay so put them on a platform
anything maybe at home how do you get
that how do you do that well you start
with some great treats and i we like
these barkworthies he'll do anything for
a bark wear these and we start with
luring
so there we go from luring
and then eventually you can get your dog
to climb up you start with maybe a lower
platform
you know just something yeah a few
inches off the off the floor
and then from there i use what's called
an air cookie i pretend i have a cookie
oh and and now i treat with the other
hand
so that way they don't okay i was gonna
say because you don't want to fake your
dog out right i'd always heard you don't
want to pretend and then never give them
the treat exactly so you're just doing
it with a change of hand bingo okay yeah
and then that becomes a hand signal so
here we go
and then hand signal
see how that's a hand signal and then
again treat with the other yeah he's got
a bark worthy there you go buddy okay
so there he
from there
here's another trick that's really fun
to do with your dog
it's called footsies
oh my goodness right
we do first peek-a-boo
so start with your dog behind lure
forward
and then
and then you
safely put your feet like this lure your
dog up onto your feet and then little by
little start to jiggle your toes and
before that what do you know
we can do the roomba look at that
spider's so smart uh
a little bit smarter than maybe some of
the other he's above my pay grade i'll
tell you that much like you said you
could do this with any dog and i i oh my
goodness i know he's so ready i think
the big benefit so what you the reason
some people may say why do i need to
train my dog it knows how to sit what is
the reason socialization is the key it's
so important that a dog can be in our
world
right if a dog is not socialized well
right then dog doesn't get as many
benefits doesn't right so the um the
benefit of training
is that the dog can be in our world
and have more liberties
come on buddy just like spider hair okay
and so folks and now you're based out of
los angeles you're here for super zoo
how can they find you larry k dot com
kay that is yeah i see all kinds of
videos with spider i make videos with
shelter dogs to help them get adopted
and teach them dog tricks and we know
there's a lot of dogs out there right on
the very first day of training and so i
love going into shelters with that and
bringing
thank you so much for coming on the show
this morning
there's the star of the show mary jane i
have to send it over to you because i
know we have a lot of weather to talk
about but
how great is this this is my favorite
part of today already watching